considera la tabla con los valores de la
función fx igual a x al cuadrado entre
11 de x para valores positivos de x
cercanos a 0 observa que falta un valor
en la tabla este es el valor que falta
usar la calculadora para evaluar f x en
x igual a 0.1 y escribe ese número en la
tabla redondeando a tres posiciones
decimales a partir de la tabla escribe
el límite unilateral al cual el límite
cuando x se aproxima a 0 desde el lado
positivo de x cuadrada entre 1 - jose 9
x parece acercarse x cuando es igual a 1
f x va a ser igual a 2.175 cuando x se
acerca un poquito más a 0
recordemos que nos estamos aproximando a
0 desde valores mayores que 0 esto es lo
que nos indica este subíndice más aquí
cuando x es igual a 0.5 fx es 2.0 42
cuando nos acercamos aún más a 0 0.2 en
x es igual a 2.007 y yo supongo que
conforme me voy acercando más
pero me voy a ir acercando a un f x 2
pero vamos a verificar lo saquemos la
calculadora quiero evaluar x cuadrada
entre 1 - coseno de x cuando x es igual
a 0.1 y lo primero que quiero hacer es
verificar que mi calculadora se
encuentren radiales si no voy a obtener
resultados muy raros y si estoy en modo
radiales
vamos a evaluarlo voy a tener 0.1 al
cuadrado
entre dos puse un paréntesis en lugar de
la diagonal entre 1 menos coseno de 0.1
esto me da 2.000 a 1 667 pero nos están
pidiendo redondearlo a tres posiciones
decimales así que esto va a ser dos
puntos 0.02 así que parece que el límite
se aproxima a dos no se aproxima a 2.005
porque este valor ya lo pasamos justo
ahorita que acabamos de evaluar x punto
uno nos dió 2.002 revisamos nuestra
respuesta y es correcta y a mí me gusta
graficar estas funciones y de hecho para
eso es bueno esta calculadora que
grafica vamos a graficar la nos vamos al
modo gráfica le dije no me funciona aquí
va a ser x al cuadrado dividido entre
1 - coseno de x y vamos a asegurarnos
que el rango de la gráfica sea correcto
y veamos el rango bueno me interesa
acercarme a 0 desde la dirección
positiva pero siempre y cuando yo vea
los valores cercanos a 0 puedo dejar
este valor así aunque pueda acercar un
poco más mi valor mínimo de x va a ser
menos 1 mi valor máximo de x aquí en la
tabla es 1 pero para tener un poquito
más de espacio vamos a hacerlo de 1.5 la
escala en x es 1 el mínimo de g
aquí según la tabla es aproximándose a 2
así que el máximo de jay puede ser
bastante más pequeño lo dejamos en 3 y
vamos a graficar esto vemos cómo se está
dibujando
aquí está de hecho pareciera que nos
aproximamos a este límite también desde
el lado negativo de las equis así como
si nos aproximamos al 0 desde el lado
positivo y en ambos casos el valor de la
función se aproxima 2 pero en este
problema sólo nos interesa aproximarnos
a 0 desde la parte positiva así que este
es el lado que nos interesa del límite y
aquí se muestra el 2